welcome to this past weekend we have a
guest today and this episode is brought
to you by gray block pizza and gray
block pizza is a beautiful spot and if
you've ever enjoyed something like pizza
then you know what I'm talking about
they have specialty pies the zingaro the
Frenchie the hunter the deep cheese
where you at baby I'm in a deep cheese
and that is gray block pizza they also
have bronx-born pizza and that's up in
Bend Oregon gray block in Los Angeles
Bronx born in Bend those are our hitters
today's episode is brought to you by
unruly bastards and that I'm not talking
about your stepdads I'm talking about
this beautiful little card game unruly
bastards is a hilarious party game if
you like partying with friends and
sometimes you want to have more fun than
that then you can have this game
it's super fun it's simple to play you
grab a card it has a theme on it the
theme on my card says mean things to say
to a baby and I would think mmm
I hope you don't learn all the vowels so
that might be something mean to say to a
baby you know then you're just gonna
have a little consonant child but you
have to come up with the best answers to
win and become the unruly bastards it's
live on Kickstarter right now this is
your chance to get it in the first two
owner it's only 20 dollars and you're
supporting this company to create more
games so go to unruly bastards calm and
support their Kickstarter and you'll get
this bad ass game 20 bucks
unruly U n R u ly bastards dot-com have
you ever had a mole or a cyst or a group
of moles like a whole Hill full of moles
on your back or near your butt well I
know that feeling even though I've never
had it because I've carried a wallet in
the back of my pants and it feels just
like a big chunk of extra just milling
around my butt cheek and now those days
are over
because Ridge wallet has that new front
pocket
and it's that beautiful front hitter and
if you got credit cards and this and
that you know some cash you know maybe a
driver's license something like that you
can put it all into that Ridge wallet
and keep it up front and they have laser
beams cannot get through the ridge
wallet so if you're in a place and
people have lasers you're fine the ridge
wallet is that front pocket carry why
carry your stuff in the back like a
freaking mole person and just for our
listeners we have a 10% off discount go
to Ridge wallet dot-com slash theö
and use promo code théo go to Ridge
wallet dot-com slash Theo and use promo
code Theo
they also have knives what's up guys
I'll be in Charlotte next weekend at the
comedy zone and he will be in Seattle
and his name he is today's guest he was
in the he played Division some
subdivision football not in a
subdivision but like in a lower division
and he also was a wrestler ladies and
gentlemen our guest today mr. Brendan
Schaub
[Music]
Dadu Brendan Schaub ladies and gentlemen
big brown didn't people call him dude I
heard a black woman call you browned in
the around yeah yeah I get that a lot
Wow I don't crack them either like word
up I mean your mother
where do your mother do you have a lot
of black fans you seem like a kind of
guy who yeah I could see that in the wet
black women I feel like as the big girls
shout out to have a big girls I could
see that boy then them Hardy boy the
Hardy Boys yeah the Hardy boy the Hardy
Boys Doug oh this one I meant like when
one time I had the hardest hips I've
ever seen in my life bro damn just real
almost like we went hard you mean like
like she swelled up like quads like she
got them one too thick thighs they get
at KFC no white meat
no no the mmm this was more like an it
almost seemed like more of an infected
kind of gristle meaning gristle I didn't
see many veins in it bright-eyed almost
seemed like would like say if you like
said you know it's been a good year you
know I hope it's a great spring you know
and then you could knock on her leg oh
wow now did she have a huge [ __ ] as well
most girls don't have those big quads
nah man we don't have all that in here
right I don't know I don't what you into
bro dude I'm into [ __ ] being a
straight-up champion here um you're a
straight-up champ I'm not Matt your
outfit today you're not not a g-star oh
yeah this is you start where you start
raw - this is organic raw yeah they
really really emphasize the raw don't
[ __ ] chilled you start right you a
little bit and no joke you see you look
decent bro but you also look like
probably you look like the assistant
coach on the women's golf team at
Rutgers that's what I feel like that's
not bad that's not bad
you look like the creepy high school
women's volleyball coach who [ __ ] all
the players and it gets busted hot it's
frosted fun come on you look like a high
school lacrosse coach who [ __ ] the
players Oh what are the players boys or
girls girls doesn't matter
it's all
illegal its but I just want to know from
her peace of mind but you look good man
not don't tell me that after the Hat
why not bro cuz that's like some of
those some of those lacrosse coaches are
a dime pieces and they're coaching the
women's team then they just start
[ __ ] a hot one man you look like the
guy that gets beat at the first round of
every video game bro it is frustrating
you look like the kid he goes with our
kid but stew broke so he watches
everybody bro that move was sick
uh yeah yeah back up bro that was a
thank you then you back the [ __ ] up bro
my parents love me you have no quarters
that was me bro and when that dude was
done I would go up real quick and try to
touch the controls to see if it was
still worth a little hopefully these dad
some lies left yes it and then just push
the little slots in for the quarters man
okay what's tell you what else you look
like the dude goes at Dave & Buster's at
Howard the [ __ ] old you're still talking
trying to jump and crawl up to this
[ __ ] skeeball pull the balls out
[ __ ] play track yourself bro you look
like Dave Boston I could do the make
shady carnival games man the place is
shady as [ __ ] one of my friends went
missing in there this guy Jeremy that I
used to go to high school with makes
sense I wouldn't trust it ever seen him
no I don't trust it I've ever seen that
guy and if you look at our kids now the
graphics are weak compared like ps4 is
and [ __ ] yeah oh and it's so dark you
can't see like how dirty it is if you go
into like those you know game works or
Dave & Buster's first of all they're
selling alcohol and video games right
next to each other and kids yeah area
too bro and then you can collect all the
tokens and like buy some weird [ __ ] you
don't want and the tokens are garbage
man yeah that's [ __ ] on my face I just
discovered some underworld there are
professional Dave & Buster's guys that
go there they win tickets and then they
buy the [ __ ] and sell it for above what
they got there's a whole underworld
really yeah yeah good dark web of losers
basically if you go to Dave & Buster's
without a military discount you've
already lost that's that's rule number
one
but when you're buying token oh wow
she got to enlistment did you ever throw
it's a little strange that Nick knows
all that that's a little too much info
you seemed are you the guy who does that
I was investigating so you see if it
side hustle maybe but what it surprised
me if you did that I don't job when Nick
was pretty mature baby - and I've told
you that yeah I know I know I know but
um and yeah well it happens look man we
all have you know some of us are born
too early and some of us are born too
late you know it's almost hang out at
Dave and Buster's we can [ __ ] hustle
kids out of there token Brendan Schaub
is here um dude do you I was thinking
about this the other day do you cuz you
played football and then you played
fighting yeah you don't play fight but
you guys carry on well dude I watch them
your videos are it's you basically beat
beating fat guys up I don't have you
seen some of the fights oh oh
one of them's at a mall it's not - who
is that guy one of them you're punching
a black I was on the ground which is
basically like illegal illegal estate
yeah that's a good point I was in I
think Washington it's cool there do you
ever see a fight and you think like and
you you feel the desire in you to be
back out there no never not at all yeah
but outside it too busy like outside of
like the business side of it you know
like you like it is it is it in your in
my nature yeah like in your I mean
competition is but that was a kid
growing up with a brother or playing
football or whatever I'm doing whether
it's a podcast and making sure I'm still
on the top in the ranking so it's always
there's the competitions always there I
don't hit people right I have no desire
my life is way better now I never looked
back you never looked back
what's the toughest hit that you've
taken physically since you got out of
the UFC I mean physically I don't get
hit him I don't spar anything like rapid
you fall down or slip on some stuff on a
marble slip on oh I was my kid got that
like this little scooter like a thing
and I was running down like backwards
trying to be out always chasing me and I
ate [ __ ] and all the parents saw it pop
that buzzing [ __ ] as fun yeah that's so
embarrassed
do you like if your kid do you have to
UM take your kid on play dates and stuff
like that or no
ah I mean he went to a birthday party
the other week but not really when
they're two and a half they kind of stay
to themselves oh really your kids only
two and a half years old and a half mmm
do you think your kid seems like a
strong baby or not yeah he's a little
freak
he was enough two and a half year old oh
one thinks he's four yeah freak oh yeah
I could see that and there but every
parent says that like using the 99% out
not [ __ ] for reals my kids a giant
yeah every parent says that like oh he
said you know we got the test back he's
so smart
yeah well he's regular Yeah right he's
so smart he's so fast
well he's - yeah that fast are you
[ __ ] your kids not special
yeah he's ever they're eating dirt out
of a plant pot yeah it's not no that's
not working every parent thinks our kids
special yeah cute I'm ready to tell you
you're full of [ __ ] dude do you think
that in the future that like do you
think there's a next level of like UFC
kind of fighting where people are
fighting animals and stuff like that or
do you think that this is kind of where
as far and as brutal as it goes hmm as
far as brutal that we're there we we've
reached the threshold but the the
athletes will get better like you have
kids now who are training in mixed
martial arts oh I'm not training just
Ajit's or just box and just wrestling
like most guys are today or you know
from my generation so you're gonna have
actual kids who have their black belt
and mixed martial arts they're not just
specialists so the sport will grow as
far as the athlete but as far as
popularity I you know I think we've hit
a cap I think we've hit a cap
do you think that that the sport overall
has gotten softer over time or like
because football obviously if you're
watching an NFL this year like it's good
it's bad like this is so bad you watch
champ a Pittsburgh uh there's like four
ruffling the past calls in the first
quarter what did I see I didn't see the
first quarter I saw the last quarter
it's [ __ ] but yeah
voicemail about that too if you want
here we did yeah yeah let's hear it my
my question for both you and Vernon is
have you seen [ __ ] [ __ ] going on
in NFL now clay Mathews [ __ ] has
three dude buzzing look at what with
this [ __ ]
I'd like to know either you or brin have
to say about the current state but
roughing the passer and then FL and if
you think they should let them big boys
hit hard
Tim big boy that sounds like you want to
see them hit hard was he in water
bobbing up and down like that yeah that
guy might have autism the guy might live
in a bubble who knows what this kid is
one of a video of them doing no it's
frustum me it's more frustrating because
they go alright you can't land on the
quarterback can do this so when they go
okay what should we do they don't know
right they have no explanation
so if footballs football we got to take
it for what it is right
football is a violent [ __ ] game and
violent give me some consequences for
playing that game yeah is the juice
worth the squeeze most guys think so
yeah so let them do that just because
the general audience go oh my god to run
into each other there's heavy
consequences we need to change the game
no no that's the [ __ ] game that's it
man right that's what the game is leave
it Liat alone will you have now also you
got all of these Wildcats out there like
all like every former NFL player like
they're all in these unions where
they're just trying to get more money
time because of issues now from when
they were fighting right like I ran into
an attorney of the day I told you about
this dude he's the attorney I ran into
him in that in the circle-k parking lot
right him and his kid where did you hit
- when he yells out wreck mother no shut
up like and I've ran into him twice well
the second time I was like what do you
do he's like if you ever get in the NFL
that's what he tells me if you ever get
in the NFL and play for a few years and
get hurt call me he's Frank jeiza well I
don't know who the [ __ ] he is but I'm
not getting in the NFL you don't 38
years shout-out to Frank hey dude
so he defends listen but here's what he
said he goes there are so many players
now that I I represent all the players
that get out of the league and then I
represent them in cases Indian against
the NFL class-action suits against the
NFL to get money for the injuries and
the lifestyle that they live now yeah
that's great and they should be
compensated and they could easily do
that each team could put up a few
hundred thousand dollars a year and
cover every you know former player as
far as injuries go I don't know if they
deserve a
per diem every year something like that
yeah they should have insurance for the
rest of their lives for what they went
through
okay pay for insurance what I should get
I think a free wheelchair something I
think what it was that they had um you
know that guy that caught the Pittsburgh
miracle or whatever no here's Franco
Harris they gave him like a special
wheelchair when he retired like get the
[ __ ] out of here the more did would eat
what do you do though yeah I mean you
can trace them and a lot of wheelchairs
get rusty dude and shout out to
Pittsburgh dude I got pinkeye in
Pittsburgh one time one of the strongest
cases ever dude thought of do it spread
through my bloodstream give me a staph
infection of both of my knees feel City
pinkeye bro oh dude it was a lady from
ah wheeling from West Virginia fart in
your face
no she just straight-up looked at me
brother
I'm that dude I'll use it from someone
coughing and farting in your face Robin
and all that poll me neither bro but so
lame they stand up fart in your face you
know how that happened what kind of
plane at you on dude
when Pittsburgh were you a dude or you
want a private jet with Andy Dick not
Southwest oh yeah southwestern Southwest
is the [ __ ] Greyhounds of the Year
bro oh dude gray Hannah you ever flown
spirit huh
your phone's spiritair yeah you end up
better in lawn chairs and don't ask for
water do not ask for water like water
the [ __ ] out of like you gotta see here
I saw a father save up all the saliva
and is nothing in spitting to his kids
man got it bro you got it
Oh mathroom that's better but yeah
Pittsburgh shitty panties you know
six-hour flight [ __ ] your pants don't
fly spread it international
oh I flew West yet we have seat belts
bro I flew West jet up to Canada and uh
and it was horrible man all the lights
were on the whole flight it was an
all-night fight the ladies we can't get
the lights in the wall I've one spirit
and they only had the heat blast my
summer six-hour flight son in New York
damn everybody's cutting weight
everybody in that sauna everyone the big
girl complaining the worst one you
probably needed more than any mom knock
on wood yeah and there ain't no you're
not
rehydrating they don't have nuts
no peanuts nothing dude I was just up in
Toronto man some reviewer wrote like a
shitty review of my show up there and
they were all awesome
where did they write it on your
Instagram just something somebody sent
me a link and it was just why are you
reading that stuff I really I don't know
what the link was you know worked on it
yeah and it was like someone like throws
I'm funny
well it was just like this
self-proclaimed redneck that's what they
saying that [ __ ] made me mad bro you
know that's not my thing
ya know I don't who use a [ __ ]
so I help me how many takers you sell in
Toronto let's say 1200 let's say
everyone let's say 15,000 tickets yeah
15,000 people 14,000 998 loved the show
right two [ __ ] who are jealous of
your success and where you're what
you're doing now you're online and
drawing any haircut and potato nose
they're all hating on you no I'm saying
and clavicles brah I think I could be
better
what are you talking about here's some
for Chester bro you got mad that Indiana
Jones Temple of Doom chess nerd bro
you're making my Calista Flockhart we
got a couple of questions that came in
from in a shop and then we got an
announcement to make
big announcement okay now swim bro oh
what's up big enough see 229 then we got
announcement for that ass yeah boy let's
take a call a question or two that came
in here for burnished I'll or these live
or these guys monitor these these have
been monitored all right yeah I feel hi
Brendan I'm Louis I'm from England
I'm a massive fan of both yours the fire
and the kid and this past weekend
two-bit question really won Brendan
keeps talking about the sting and the
King podcast
she wanna know if that is gonna happen
because if it was I can't wait for it
and second part do you have any plans on
coming over to England any time soon
there's no England what shut us Oh
England by Scotland yeah I would love to
come to England dude up in there bro
you have there last year this was also
amazing amazing that'd be dope to do
good people huh great Pete
I'd love to go to some best grabs I've
ever seen ever dude I went to I did some
military bases over there a long time
ago
really yeah it's pretty nice ears fun
man I love it over there
yeah British people are uh because
here's the thing they're original
Americans no say no white dude if you go
back I'm surprised there's not a boat
leaving here soon being like [ __ ]
America we're going back I agree they
got they still got kings and queens over
there like it's Game of Thrones or so
they're jesters a friend of mine got a
job as a gesture over there bawling -
they get benefit o jesters get a lot of
huh yeah you know about a low-key hey
did you ever seen the soldiers over
there yeah the guards those those boys
don't move
well do to fight with that tall hat on
has to be absolutely your marksmanship
your posture Oscar I couldn't do it the
posture Oh fighting with that hot hat on
while other animals are trying to [ __ ]
your hat dude cuz it looks like a buff
probably five and go outside out of my
hair at night I'll turn around some rows
are like seven raclette me behind me
yeah they want your locks yeah [ __ ] yeah
oh there he is right there
hey and you can even get this close to
him you ever seen the one where dude
keeps [ __ ] with him and he just
knocks him out mm-hmm he just knocks to
do that punch him square in the jaw not
come out and then doesn't move just
stands like that the biggest dick energy
you've ever seen dude the Royal Air
Force or some I think that's what
they're called man some of the baddest
has - driver mayor growls is anyone yep
used to mean Bear Grylls bro no bill
growls bear growls is uh is a
early-onset sign of diarrhea I don't
know what station you're watching on but
I watch on a bootleg youtube that's what
they call them bro
so I'm not rich like deal Vaughn rich
bro what are you talking about man rich
look at you man what's up bro what do
you what do you do one with the G star
role on dude this is one shirt and I
actually stole this out of Chris Chris
Leah's car at the Comedy sense but yeah
what was the first part of the guy's
question he asked about this King and
the sting thing
yeah bro let the people know talk to you
people yeah I mean I think yeah we got
an announcement to make that we are
going to be starting the king in the
sting podcast October she comes out fire
poker oh that's happening singing the
king a little bit about it's gonna be
all fanbase driven in at the fan driven
so this is gonna be each time you know
every week you guys are gonna be able to
submit you know themes and verses things
you want to see burning out discuss
topics topics argue should we king
things or sting things you send videos
pictures we can roast your aunt if you
want yes your fat ass grandma whatever
your weird stepbrother with the [ __ ]
[ __ ] I will do that roast this funeral
bro I'm at the shittiest funeral right
yeah King at our sting it is this guy
going that is my aunt going to heaven or
hell right most my family dinner will
roast like [ __ ] your mom's weak-ass
meatloaf bro send us a strong look man
if you want to send us you know what
you'll be able to send those pictures
videos absolutely everything he's gonna
be super interactive great my sex tape
yeah what how's your dick bro how's that
hip thrust
we'll see bro yeah how's your girl suck
dick I don't know no come on no it's way
chillier than that wait chill I'm sorry
yeah it's like what do you think um I
got carried away yeah what do you think
my car yeah adult asthma is it real yeah
you know this haircut yeah internet'
ROYGBIV you know so there's just gonna
be a lot of different options my dick
have a weird color I don't know but
that's a good question is the limit bro
my brother had the darkest looking dick
I've ever seen my brother has the dark
are you serious yeah looks like an
elephant trunk oh it looked like there's
an eclipse happening at the same time
every time I saw my brother looks like
it just has a shadow over its are like
someone just holding a hand over and the
sun's above is here all the time oh my
brother's dick was so low on chlorophyll
it was unbelievable oh yeah my brother
gray my mother got that dark night [ __ ]
I wonder if that's just like a younger
brother thing where you see your brother
and you in it's like it's dark and it
looks dark because it's not supposed to
be appealing to you since it's your
brother's you know it's like our filter
since we're little brothers right it's
like oh I saw the other day we're in
Chicago
and he came out the shower and it looked
like an elephant's holding water he
looks like the trunk I went bro let him
I don't breathe bro and why so dark is
this the way that's Wow feel like
Montana on it that's a kind of wood it
seemed like it my brother had that kind
of the bronzer it was African like if
you looked at my brothers like from
lower bodies seem like the first two
episodes of roots have you ever seen
roof oh yeah it was just like that it
was very everything was dark and very
you know um like that George Orwell book
or whatever into the jungle or whatever
it's called yeah one brothers more like
Django in my dog over the place really
yeah as like Django is like chaos Oh God
who's chaos is sound like a bad guy you
know it's just problems oh it is yeah
like you needs to be relieved all the
time Jesus King listings drop in October
yeah hopefully is going to drop a little
bit better than our oldest dude I wonder
no wonder that man what I was just
trying to wonder who's older brother had
a better [ __ ] honestly but I don't want
her and here's the thing I've never
thought about my brother's penis my
entire life until just now and I don't
ever want to again yeah me neither
we got a question about job and his
brother yep let's send it in man hey
what's going on to you the questions for
Brennan job its shell yes Halloween's
coming up and he's really tight with his
older brother just curious if they have
any like hilarious stories from like
trick-or-treating why I mean they look
like a couple bags mattress like they're
out there smashing candy not even earn
it the hard way but anyways I agree with
that man now when Denis can't snatch
people's bags I thought you work hard
for them you can't steal other kids
candy you look like a bag snatcher get
it you guys have any wild times or did
you guys even go trick-or-treating
together
[ __ ] yeah went trick-or-treating Tara's
bro [ __ ] went trick-or-treating
together
yeah some goddamn Americans really yeah
I dressed up as a French robot French
robot there's pictures of it French kid
Finns are familiar with this Brody the
French robot
I drew a mustache I mean then I gave out
my mom's croissants and she was not
happy
I only had 12 there I am French robot
what's up bro what the [ __ ] is up bro
dude you look like a lego person hey
look at my eyebrows up my French I don't
know I was weird my mom my mom goes what
do you wanna be and my mom's really good
at sewing and making costumes I said a
French robot and moms like Wow
weird kid but alright let me see what I
can do she made the robot she doesn't
know how we make this French I went haha
and then put on the eyebrows bro but now
you can see like a young Salvador Dali
up in that [ __ ] and then was just
slanging slanging them croissants my mom
went what the [ __ ] we don't hand out
croissants I love them dude now you look
a little bit more like bebop and
rocksteady had a [ __ ] had a third
brother that try to do music can you
pull up the pocket minute and Rocksteady
please bro you look like you look like
Casey from the Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles with Down syndrome and I beat
downs it like Casey bro yeah well I beat
Down syndrome I don't know who Casey you
know those Casey is from TNA general
store who's always trying to [ __ ] April
uh and he drove the van had that
bullshit-ass
dude you're Casey you you look like
Captain Planet instead of saving the
planet you just [ __ ] suck [ __ ] bring
up Captain Planet for me you look
identical damn if you're a superhero
you're Captain Planet to the max nah
he's the weakest a superhero bro he was
a captain of a whole planet that's you
matey
look at the clavicles it does I ate my I
could do more traps work and he
definitely has that body I will have
that body soon dude you're on them roids
back on them Roy I'm not getting back
all over on the side of the highway star
injector oh do you don't know how you
get steroids anymore man
one guy I bought something awful one
that's Casey by the way you look like
Captain Planet the worst superheroes of
all time we that dumbass that's a
superhero that's Casey he fights crime
bro yeah he doesn't really fight it one
[ __ ] shot son wearing kid at a time
he
you gotta steal stuff from Hot Topic
does it looks like you protects hot top
feel like stealing from that story
Oh Captain Planet who that you captain
Theo bro I like that man I could be
Captain Planet brah which planet though
maybe Saturn man captain Saturn nah
sounds too big
how about Uranus nah you're anything you
know Pluto they shut it down member
Pluto was something I know it's just not
there anymore yeah I got all the hype
and kind of went away how crazy was that
that one hit wonder bro King at her
stinging you think Pluto
[ __ ] Pluto too far away don't like the
name yeah I like the Disney character
though yeah I would say staying Pluto
because first of all it wasn't
remembered they were just suddenly like
hey Pluto doesn't exist you're like well
what about the [ __ ] four months I
learned about it in school bro you at
the name the plants I had to build the
[ __ ] diagram yeah that [ __ ] all
that [ __ ] was even real they're like
it's really cold and we don't know much
about it to talk about some [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know who got all the hype
was Mars [ __ ] yeah
everyone's gonna Mars aliens the red
it's all red yeah minstrel you know we
got the Rovers on there yeah well dude
the rover there let's talk about that it
was like a seventy billion dollar no
control car remote control car that they
lost once it lent once it landed and the
[ __ ] video would take yeah tell me
nothing cost seven billion dollars so
you could have made a much better video
and hey chess yeah yeah I say actually
dude who's that chick I say yeah sting
that one man sting the rover sting the
whole Mars landing bro sting the whole
[ __ ] galaxy dude to be honest with
you you're trying to go to zip or Elon
taking people to the moon not Mars is
easy with a moon just Japanese people
yeah well I could I think they deserve
to get there first man they've been
patient and they're very smart are you
gonna sin I don't know yeah I wouldn't
go I could see trying to go up there if
it was part of some you know bad
television show you were on like that
Bravo show you just did what was that oh
it sucked only 1.5 million people tuned
in really stupid
what am I gonna do yes I don't know man
what are we talking about though what
we're talking about god I'm sorry man
produced by Andy Cohen oh my god what am
i do Danny Cohen offered to blow me one
time easy-easy I want no part no he
didn't know he said he would bang me
though so that's difficult looking dude
yeah Jericho knows on there he's our boy
Jerry man I love both of those guys yeah
he's great Michael yours and there was
he talking about Michael yo at all was
he talking about him no it's just like
him I hear Michael yo he knows about
Michael yo look at Jericho looking like
he was at the beach Jericho mo does not
age is he had work done now no I was
trying to look at his face and I can
tell sometimes he's just like an they
just wonder yeah
any Silurian yeah Jerry O'Connell is
amazing man one of the best storytellers
I've ever met um but yellow so let's
talk more about King in the sting bro
what's up bro when's he gonna come out
October yeah early October sweat but
tell them the one thing we're doing
we're linking up with a little company
called candor yeah you guys can submit
all your videos questions themes
whatever you want feel and I to discuss
yeah through this app called candor yeah
and we'll put out a video in the next
week explaining it all explaining
exactly how to do it but also well it's
this would be the first ever fan driven
show yeah where you guys pick the themes
what do you want us to break down and
also you'll be appearing on the show as
well and this Kander app is actually
being built specifically for your guys's
show correct
yeah like it so it's gonna be super easy
for the fans to submit yeah and you
don't have to have the app you can have
just a website you can go to you have to
sign it doesn't cost anything you just
go to it and submit your video and then
the pick and choose the best one so the
movie breaking yeah we're not gonna pick
and choosing the producers are so we'll
have no idea yeah we'll have no idea so
it'll be some surprise to us every time
and we'll discuss the themes and we'll
you know shoot them up or shoot them
down it could be anything anything
who's better Joker Jared Leto Heath
Ledger and then you I just go at it yeah
it's a hot Dom who's lingering spare key
yeah
penguins parakeets Asians blacks yeah
for porno oh yeah yeah yeah um marbles
are juggling you know and marbles is
just you know it's kind of like orange
ground juggling yeah you know easier
yeah gravity or friction hmm um what
else
Gatorade or Powerade yeah fresca Dr
Pepper fresque is a definitely drink of
gentlemen well it's like it's basically
like a roller coaster for a senior
citizen
fresca probably one of the 70 worst
drink ever goddamn I know we've talked
about this for I know they're fresh yeah
they're fresh they're not fresh dude
it's in a can it's in the [ __ ] title
bro came from another country
yeah and they miss and they white and
dr. pepper ain't coming from a doctor
drink that [ __ ] okay but it used to
it was originally created by a doctor in
Florida you idiot and coca-cola doesn't
have coconut anymore but you drink that
[ __ ] don't you yeah Dre doesn't have
no Gator butter right but fresca has the
fresh raw milk has milk in it and if you
if you get coke and you just catch a
little gram breathing you good you know
what I'm saying you doubt you [ __ ]
out up and then you take a couple rounds
house that's now you take a couple
ounces to the throat yeah people like do
do you ever do cocaine I said what this
knows why I did it all oh yeah don't
mean you know cocaine party I'll do
coriander I'll do it from across this
[ __ ] snout I got so that's it man we
got the king of the stink coming up side
for a minute ID - we've had a lot of
planning to stop going into it
and I think the reason for me is because
you know so many people just asked about
it man I know when I'm on the road dude
you ain't do ya do you until you do
something yeah you and he'll come bang
my sister I was like damn bro you until
run a train on my mom I was like we got
to do something I don't know if we're
gonna run trailing homeboys mom but we
should do a show oh dude I'll bring that
Polar Express brought one of my tricks
is putting my dick and ice and then
[ __ ] with it yeah I'll flood [ __ ] in
the uh-huh yeah somethin die bro no I
don't do all that violence stuff
it's not violent I like this to surprise
them with that low-key coldcock
especially if it's in the summer
oh [ __ ] turn you in that cold salami we
did if you tell a chick hey you want to
come back to my room for some icy meat
we're like your how about subway yeah
hot and cold mmm you give it up cold ice
bring in the hot oh yeah we're not doing
anything like that no that's not what
we're doing
well what I'm saying you know people
were asking us to do a show yeah and
that's a and it's once a week - dude how
is it that every time we're gonna subway
there's a roach somewhere crawling
around but I still get a sandwich that's
why don't [ __ ] in the subway bro Oh ever
since Jared started jacking off in the
mayonnaise and [ __ ] and molesting kids
I'm out bro I don't know if he did that
oh it's confirmed ed he's in prison
right now for it dude this is Josh Knopf
with the ham this is a true story I
could see that
I mean ham will make anybody want to
come but I'll also say this that his
sister gave me a bj and this is probably
about 16 years ago in the French Quarter
in Louisville
yeah did you know is Jared sister yeah
yeah and you say take that pipe I'll
really take that high end of June are
these Edie selfish was she things like
Double Dragon the something like line to
use her to fight in that Double Dragon
video yeah that's one of the cons or any
youporn pretty watch what double drag
are you playing brought them off for I
talk about surfing sport let that video
game take the pipe yeah I'm almost 48
hours stay I'm looking a sister bro she
boxed there you struck she wasn't are
you [ __ ] but tell them just like
Matilda Bob tip you look I'd rather to
get a [ __ ] from Jared dude you look
like a lesbian golf pro dude you throw
on the core you gave her a footlong look
like an assistant coach that gets a
table at the club all right it's your
[ __ ] life together oh I gotta correct
those bad googling that was his ex-wife
Oh God Matilda look a woman Wadley is
she
looks vaguely familiar that's a tough
part don't touch me dude come on bro DAP
it up I'm not no I'm cops or [ __ ]
Jerrod sister in the mouth through your
mouth bro watch them your fighting
videos the other day one of them's you
just beaten up a [ __ ] you're a
security guard you're beating up a fat
guy at a mall a lot of it was just you
punching fat dude
hey that's fine you [ __ ] your sister bro
bro I got oral sex first of all in the
French Quarter huh yes just some
beignets and [ __ ] her in the mouth or
what bro bro no there were a bunch of
French robot did you get a [ __ ]
classic meatball and then have a suck
your dick dude you get it you get a
meatball sub and a suck you are profane
bro this guy's out of his mind
I don't like she's not herself
no she's bringing her help down no no we
don't do that to the poor lady but we
please after the show I'm gonna Google
it for sure we do want to bring up we do
want to bring up the next question that
we have for Brennan though this funny
dude
Giovanni huge fan man think this is an
awesome portion of the show I got a
quick question for Brendon I've been
trying to ask me for a little while now
and the question is Brendon would you
unblock me on Instagram Wow little
backstory
I made a massive mistake a little over a
year ago commenting something about
Erika lani being taken off the show time
it doesn't really matter is a huge
mistake it's probably elbow deep in the
bag cheetahs at the time when I asked it
I should have never said anything about
it he goes on to say he's a huge fan
listens to all the podcast buys her
coffee and he literally I'm begging you
uh he didn't leave it he did and he said
he's gonna comment on Chin's post okay
if I find him that's true yet it depends
what he said and a lot of times I don't
deal with that that someone goes through
and elites all the trolls and all that
yeah with any of it but if it's like he
was talking [ __ ] day or hewan about
getting fired from show time or and how
I should have stepped down not taking
the job or I don't know what it was a
lot of that stuff's too much a lot of it
though like it's it's the world's - your
life's too short to deal with any
negativity yeah if it's even like you
like blue I like green you get
right damn yeah yeah on the day yeah I
keep people out that sent me like a lot
of people send me lewd stuff a lot of
dudes sending pictures of that back hole
we got a lot of uh you know blocking
this in that backhoe oh dude I block him
one dude for a long time was sitting me
I couldn't tell what it was and it was
pictures and it kept Zook going further
and further out and it was his weiner
hole dude you know give him a courtesy
[ __ ] follow for that [ __ ] no dude I
was getting some [ __ ] for a while
really yeah and then finally I don't
want hurt anyone's feelings sorry man I
appreciate that for you put in so in
these pictures and some are some
actually nice aspects but it's not my
thing
yeah yeah I get a lot of training
sometimes well a lot of times especially
you can't tell it first you're like dang
you know this seemed like a cute lady
I know bro you know and you're like man
this cute lady you know nah yeah nuts
this cute lady plays men's tennis you
know saying that they let her play
she's like a pioneer and type girl you
know I mean like all this cute lady has
two sons you know still you're in the
benefit of the day yes y'all give him
the benefits to lady drives a Mustang GT
I know it's like all right that's cool
oh cool oh that's cute lady wears men's
briefs you know weird this cute lasers
down and whistle you know I'm saying oh
damn and she dips - yeah hardcore [ __ ]
on a hand this cute late he's growing a
mustache real Montana this lady has some
calluses nothing wrong with that I like
girl gets down and dirty damn she's a
construction worker what's wrong with
that either
she's a Montana 9 right here ah yeah man
you got to be careful out there but I
bought you this dude's first use you
know you saw this little picture and I
thought it was you know just kind of
this kind of pink or reddish color I'm
thinking oh it might be part of a vagina
or maybe maybe in an ant or a wound from
like a war or something you know could
people send me a lot of war wounds and
then it keeps getting further out I'm
like Oh what is that it looks like a you
know maybe something from Mars like one
of those pictures from Mars or somebody
got in their lip busted open or
something like that and then it was he
finally the last one I'm like ah
[ __ ] man talking to you yeah and yeah he
is the good camera give him that but it
was too much yeah something too much
it's just too much sorry to interrupt
guys I know you were I know you were
listening to Brendan try and think of
something but um but I'm gonna tell you
about this special sauce that makes me
think in the morning it's called Bixby
it's Bixby coffee and it's coffee you
make it home why go get coffee somewhere
at a shop you know what should be in a
shop shoes you know appliances shops for
coffee that's for rich people be a
regular person it's high-end coffee
that's more affordable than grocery
store coffee its whole being in fresh
ground under that half being Oh none of
that hbz maybe this whole bean it's
better coffee at a better price
delivered right to your door Bix peak
coffee calm even order from your
smartphone bixby coffee calm use promo
code theo th EO at checkout and your
first shipment costs just $5 thus two
weeks of coffee dos semanas they cafe
for $5 use promo code Theo
sometimes you end up hanging out in a
space with a real square and that's what
I'm doing right now this episode is
sponsored brought to you by Squarespace
from websites and online stores to
marketing tools and analytics
Squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business it's it's basically
just taking the internet into your own
control you can create a beautiful
website all-in-one platform domains
online stores marketing tools and it's
simple to set up or transfer your domain
on to Squarespace you have a GoDaddy
domain easily switch it to Squarespace
make small businesses easy head to
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com slash Theo von to save
10% off your first purchase of a website
or a domain that's squarespace.com slash
Theo von to save 10% off but
so I guess I mean I don't even know what
else to tell people man I'm excited one
one once a week hit her once a week hit
her hour-long show hour-long show see me
as good as the fans make it yup as good
I submit any themes shows you know you
like to spray anything do the Hazzard
flower and your thing yeah second start
two-story buildings you know it could be
anything you want thing McDonald's
playground yeah thoughts concerns um
group funerals you know what I'm saying
save that dime castration
yeah castration or keep it you know
boats
yeah boats brought small boats you ever
seen a dude in a [ __ ] small boat it's
weird
shut it down bro don't swim i Patrick
Sam I know just swim Oh aye patches eye
patches yea or nay oh I think it's a
good place to keep a little bit of coke
you know what I'm saying because also if
you get pulled over a lot of times even
will look behind I can't
well they'll frisk you all day but a lot
of people will look a lot of people
think this is afraid as well that
there's a spider under it that's a good
idea bro but but that'll be the episode
man I'm amazed it took you this long
even come on to this podcast you've
never invited me I don't know if that's
true I invited in the hall about 60
times really no yeah you're literally
thirty feet from here but next door
yeah old studio bro is it weird to be in
your old studio it is I don't remember
this real I just that painting it feels
like forever ago
Yeah right I'm sorry kid but I shouldn't
say rough times it was a hectic time
when we came in here was it Grambling
yeah I left Fox left Fox had two days
put together studio so we didn't miss
any shows how he's pride myself on that
we have we've never missed a show Wow
never missed a week whether you know
there's pride by himself from you by
myself we've never missed one and I
didn't want to miss one and you know Fox
and then it kind of thuggish so we left
and then was a good move was it scary to
leave um to kind of always been my thing
it wasn't scary I was just like I will
make it like we're gonna make its
podcast you know we have our audience
isn't lloyd of fox
loyal to funding the kid broke me myself
was there any fear though for a moment
like oh maybe that's what they are like
you know was there any like kind of
trepidation in that never my only fear
was that Fox was gonna be like oh we own
the name right wow that stuff but I we
had lawyers and everything so I called
them before I quit and all that yeah do
you like have you like as you get busier
like with work you know and you picked
up different you know jobs and gone from
you know really kind of evolved in a
different you know facets of
entertainment really and through through
them do you feel do you feel that you
wanted to do even more work or less work
does your do you notice that your drive
changes or do you ever find yourself
amazed at what you some of the stuff
you've been able to do not that you
doubted yourself but just like but still
then surprised it said some stuff no I
don't really think about it my drives
higher than ever I think I'm saying no
to more things right now it's all about
time if I'm gonna take time away from
being at home with my kid it better be
worth it very something I want to do
because I don't need to do anything
right I into my own podcast and stand-up
and I'm I'm straight yeah
right because with my bills covers
everything I'm good enough to do
anything nothing I don't want to do and
was there a certain point where you
realize man that's so freeing like
because I've found that like I used to
have to was awaiting for all these
networks to offer me things and like
just hopeful and stuff like that but
dude now it's like they'll call them
okay do you want to go do this and it's
like no no it's not you know I don't
need it I don't need you know I don't
need a place that a hat fell so seems
like it hasn't appreciated me a lot of
times to be like oh yeah come it's like
nah
yeah good it feels good and control a
little bit of it yeah developer control
there were several ways to go but yeah I
definitely feel like that more control
where most people have to do it but
there's still that little bit of sewing
off she's something like dang I kind of
need to do it weapons weapons if it
blows up or what if this what if I miss
this I should done this yeah that and
you did a movie recently and I saw one
of the outtakes of it and it I mean it
looked like yet on shoes it didn't fit
they hurt my feet brought nothing a feel
my boots if you've ever seen picture
let's picture Wyatt Earp but with
sensitive feet okay yeah Wyatt Earp I'm
still just like you think of Wyatt Earp
doing the crab wahoo Brendan is robbing
a bank okay with some other Banderas and
he has a gun Roe
doesn't say 47 real what I'm not
familiar with guns either but he's
walking like a ground
it's [ __ ] ha yeah in plain lava
well even elementary school I would give
anything if we could play that video man
we can't play it can we not today yeah I
can play it when the movie drops I bet
yeah I sent you like what the [ __ ]
wow I was like oh I could be an actor
after this have you been in movies I was
in one movie with the ShamWow guy
remember him who
ShamWow Vince offer well you know he had
the thing like this there was always
right here and he's like you gotta get
these rags in the bam bam him no I'm not
you don't know the ShamWow how many hits
do you take dog somebody knocked the
ShamWow guy out of you I don't know what
this works wet or dry this is for the
house the car the boat the RV ShamWow
holds twelve times its weight in liquid
look at this it just does the work why
do you want to work twice as hard
doesn't rip doesn't make a mess bring it
out you wash it in the washing machine
maybe turn on no the Germans always make
good stuff here's some clean in Germany
well they make good yeah dude I went to
house still not familiar with it he did
a movie with him it was it the worst
movie in the world he looks like an
[ __ ] it absolutely was it was voted
no he's a very nice guy it was voted
though the worst movie of the year
oh yeah Razzie yeah the movie did yeah
it was and I was just in the opening
scene yeah and I played like the guy
from 127 hours it gets his arm caught in
the rocks or whatever and I'm about to
cut my arm off and I'm making a video
for my family oh wow and then it pans
out and I'm actually got a theme park
I'm too stuck between some rocks like
it's just absolutely so it's just a
really it's a spoof movie right he
regret doing it no I thought it was fun
at the time and I actually thought I did
I mean it was ridiculous but I thought I
did a service the the job okay but he
and I became buddies for a while man for
everybody here we stand out did whenever
you'd hang out was you always have
shamwows on a minute oh dude I got like
probably six and Wow
just call them whales Wow yes Wow don't
waste your time saying shame if you
don't have to I don't remember him
you don't no no unbelievable dude he
just started selling those rags on the
boardwalk one day right had no money
like a slanging him and he found out
he's good at it
next thing you know he went and got his
own got a patent on it on the actual
ShamWow the brain all and this was the
time when they had a bunch of late-night
television spots available right oh yeah
just advertising the middle of the night
nobody's awake right it was like oh well
if I'm gonna take the rags and I'll
[ __ ] put him on there he's like for
$1,500 I got three commercials late at
night he's like I put him on to I think
it was lifetime or something he put him
on to he goes and it broke even and I
sold as many rags to pay for the 50
miles and commercials so then he's like
well maybe I need to move him to
somewhere else he moved him to Comedy
Central actually really yeah how long
ago was this this is probably 30 years
ago 25 years ago 25 years ago yelling
dude he goes and I put him on and next
thing you know it like tripled he goes
in so then I did it again and again and
again and he goes and next thing you
know he'd made 20 million dollars
selling if you do now besides collect
model cars now he just lives in LA I
think he's invested in some other things
I actually did an infomercial for him
another product called the sticky I
think it was called and I played arm
what's like an r2d2 are like a big
animal that people are afraid to see
sometimes but sometimes they see it talk
about Bigfoot yeah monster yeah I mean
this R 2 T 2 I play this I'm in the
sticky commercial play for furniture
food particles in the cabinets debris on
the stairs and even use it in the car
where's it from Bobby's you always want
to get your home Israel I think it would
know from wool - velvet problem with
that shedding [ __ ] pickup cat hairs
from clothes yeah you got or you sticky
on the leftover doll hairs on the sofa
or even stickier pets before they should
it's made of a special silicone so with
a little water the dirt comes right off
its slippery when wet sticky when dry
check this out
stop wasting 100 allas a year on paper
lip yeah maybe always in that but one of
them I ended you out bro well I play a
Chewbacca or whatever it is
oh you're all in full makeup engine oh
yeah I was at all these shoots I wrote
this whole I wrote this really yeah I
wrote all the copy for this but it was
fun were up in Toronto for a few days we
went out on Halloween and everybody
thought he was just dressed up like the
ShamWow guy he was actually him she
sounds pretty funny
interesting yeah pretty bottom nope get
him on here to talk about shamwows I'll
probably what happen come on man it's a
it's a pretty amazing story but then he
got into Scientology hope I'm out and
but anyway he made a movie a long time
ago I was like one of the worst movies
ever so he made he wanted to save up a
bunch of money and remake the movie and
make it better and that's what he did
the second time and it was all just as
bad the second time what was it called
inappropriate comedy inappropriate
comedy movie so I do spot-on title that
works
shoutout to sham spot-on titling
shoutout the ShamWow and Shamu shadow do
what have you seen blackfish
yeah I've seen blackfish it's about what
they do to blackfish down in San Diego
racist unbelievable unbelievable
unbelievable any other questions that
came in for Brennan that are good yeah
we were talking about some invites
earlier europeo
that's the beastie king when that's was
going to get you on up episode of with
Brogan on a fight companion man we would
love to hear that gonna make that [ __ ]
happen what are y'all doing Michael may
fight companions we just it's just uh
it's Kalin Eddie
Rodya myself and we watch the fights and
it's [ __ ]
is it fun the best did you watch the
fight that I dare until in it yes do you
like dare until love doing - yeah me too
um Michael by springs coming on here biz
bean bro both right one of them right he
keep changing his name action I think I
got an email really great dude is he
great dude yeah I'm really excited
really good on the mic - is he yeah I
watched a couple of his fights on my
podcast - yeah he's in entertainment now
he's he's done a bunch of movies his own
podcast
he's the host of UFC tonight yeah smart
dude smart got a really good guy when
you were um did you think once you got
into some of these sports and some ones
you got a no fighting that you would
become more of a business guy did you
see that or do you think that kind of
starts to evolve as you start to see
your place like okay I'm not gonna be
fighting anymore I'm not gonna be
playing anymore I still have a
competitive attitude I just need to find
my space or what does that kind of feel
like what do you mean like it what do
you mean like did you all wait like
because like I find for myself like I
never thought I'd be thinking more about
business type of stuff right like I was
just you know a jokester a funny guy you
know I like doing comedy I like you know
getting mental help for myself so it's
like but then now I'm starting to see
like okay I can shape my own space in
this industry you don't want people to
take advantage of you you want to be
coming because you become your own
identity your own brand and you don't
want someone else speaking free so for
me
it when I was a kid like I would I had
my own comic books I'd set up comic book
stands and [ __ ] slang comics really
this or I'd had add my own lawnmower
business when I was like 12
mmm had my own business cars and bright
posters all like draw cool posters and I
was always straight trying to like
hustle damn Oh what was the shadiest
[ __ ] you ever sold probably to somebody
I sold a when I was 7 I stuff my dad
used to have all this old like you'd
like do wood project so you know all the
weird ends you know the yeah and no one
could work with and I would hammer the
end to make it look like lizards and
then I'd paint them and I put glue all
over him and then I sold it to somebody
yeah hopefully she still has it
oh I bet she does dude I bet she does
I'm trying to think if I ever sold
something real shady like those business
mind cuz I don't even taking advantage
of a my dad the businessman so I got it
from him yeah as far as it's almost
offensive when people would go oh
Brendan's bringing his athletic work
ethic into comedy or right no there's a
sleet's have the worst work ethic you've
ever seen they're just talented yeah
there's comics of the best work ethic
you've ever seen I've also seen comics
with the worst work ethics I've ever
seen has nothing to do with sports right
I was like this since I was a kid
yeah I've always been discipline it
whether it was football fighting
stand-up podcasting whatever I do really
nothing to do with being an athlete yeah
do you still feel like an athlete or do
you feel more like a businessman um I
feel like entertainer I don't entertain
yeah businessman I don't like that stuff
takes care of itself and I look over
contracts but you know there's agents
and managers deal with that yeah and
what's your relationship you have your
brothers on the road with you a lot
my brother's my tour manager so he in
manager and so he deals with all merch
booking hotels flights everything he
deals with the club directly my brother
does a lot website design everything and
you guys have always had a good
relationship always yeah super close
who's super close and was he into that
sort of thing like what did he get into
before he started working as a man
helping manage well he so he works with
me but his full-time job he works for
Microsoft's computer program oh really
smart dude oh wow smart dude yeah but he
can do that you know he doesn't have to
be in an office so he can go remote so
he can go on the road with me and it's
dope cuz then I like going to each city
and having like seeing the comics in
that area yeah I don't like bringing I
bring hey soos trio with me all the time
yeah and I like going to that city and
seeing what their comic seems like yeah
it's a [ __ ] roll of dice I've had
some awesome ones I've had some terrible
one yeah awful one oh I had to do two we
just hold his breath one time in
Jacksonville he'd held his breath like
seven minutes that was kind of it was
out of dude who just did we're all my
white people at in the car goes yeah
we're my blacks at yeah we're the women
that like that was that holding breath
guide David Blaine set the world record
cuz I bring people to their feet yeah
bro I don't know who that was um there
was one other thing that I was gonna ask
you man I'm just sayin about this King
in the stained we're gonna have a new
site we're gonna have a new set
who set son the lease on the studio King
the sting so it's gonna be a real thing
man real thing do you guys want it in
you nervous about it at all no I think
I'm excited man I think I'm excited
about getting some you know like about
having a place to kind of joke around
more me to my podcast is a little too
serious it's like I I'd to be
no I'm sure you don't list them find the
kid or below the belt but like I've
never heard the show I'll say I love you
yeah brother and I've seen your stand-up
it's the [ __ ] you know one of the
best I'm playing the earth and you're
great but I've never heard the show so I
didn't know if this was gonna be you
know let's roast in each other for now
I've never listened the show so I don't
know yeah I see you have all these
different guests so I wasn't sure but
see with below the belt that's all
fighting man I like the podcasts it the
show's all fighting Brian the podcast
the first bits it's just life with me
and then I get into fighting and Colonel
Vince's fighting that's all fighting oh
yeah I'm sat on fighting yes oh yes I
know fight hit it's you know Brian I
doing our thing there's a little bit of
fighting but not much but then current
events this what we're doing is my
escape from all that yeah where it's
silly Theo and Brendan personalities
doing our [ __ ] thing people
submitting something and you could send
in any types of themes you know I mean
don't some don't send in hey who's gonna
win Kabir Akana that's right that want
to be entertained yeah cuz WA not me
saying not only that much about fighting
you know what I'm saying I got beat up
by a bunch of blacks and whites when I
was younger that's finished I'm probably
open 9 so if you wanna hear fighting yes
into my all fight show but if you want
to hear what we do listen king of sting
yeah add a question about Theo fighting
alright this is a question for Brendan
give it the off few months of training
who's winning in the fight between him
and CM Punk thanks oh thanks for the
question brother I appreciate you asking
the question I've never seen Thiel ever
do anything aggressive in any manner
ever except when I touch you
more than four times you kind of
flinched and your reflexes were pretty
good yeah Wow
it's extremely alarming yes yeah cuz I
don't know I don't usually been in many
fights I got beat up by a guy once a
bunch of black dudes beat me up a couple
times what else have I dude I got hit I
got into two bad car accidents on if
that counts is getting beat up mmm
but your brother would beat each other
up 2d Snyder's music oh that's true
Laura growing up scrapp least a put-on
[ __ ] rock music and beat each other
that's cool but you've never been there
like a bar fight like some disrespect
your girl and you got a bar fight
no dude even when you're all them roids
you never had no road
oh I do remember a guy stole my this was
the juvenile see da come out before they
come out of hotness Oh in Baton Rouge
and I had a copy bro at a party you know
is this where it's all fire he's yes
coverage that fire what's up bro why you
hate to touch bro I can't touch me
brother what's not like rib Ambrose good
luck in there
be a loving dude man dude I am loving
bra like that you like that dawg it from
Denver's dumb friend that shelter dog
I'm not rescue ask you it's a poor
person's dog bro I'm a rescue man yeah
not me
you're not no hell no I'm that pedigree
son oh he's that Gucci Rottweiler yeah
another rescue yes yeah that's it that
was it and the hottest track was uh the
hottest track was I mean boy back that
ass up back that ass off yeah whatever
there's some really interact that ass up
can you copy here back that ass up Oh
you's a fine [ __ ] watch your back
that ass [ __ ] watch your mouth
but he plays that anymore dude you can
hear that anywhere you can hear that it
almost at all it's almost a funeral song
these days that's so old but yeah
somebody stole it from me and I went
over and I was out there and I was just
just swinging bro yeah you don't [ __ ]
with my my [ __ ] yeah and I was just
that was just it does you know the roids
was trying to get out of your arms you
were just hope you know roid rage oh
yeah for juvenile it was awesome what do
you think he's doing now oh dude there
was there was about six months later he
got accused of chasing a woman with an
ice pick down the street in her
neighborhood next stars so he went
through some tough times I think was
just partying remember us Kapoor who
were the other big guys when the no-name
like a mystical mystical something
school that the car wash was I think
he's in prison didn't I do that he's out
now oh yeah
for doing love me yes oh yeah you would
see me girls of me shaking hands watches
yeah yeah yeah Mystica was the best and
miss school was filthy
the whole squad was nasty dude ask money
bro when I went to LSU right the back
mr. P would come in there with Silkk the
Shocker and they would stand there and
play basketball in who can hoop tow they
would play they would play three times a
week in the when they were in town in
the summer there in the rec center bro
dude silk the shock remember his joy so
at the shocker
what was his Jam uh this is a throwback
from
Silkk the Shocker had a [ __ ] hey and
one hit row and c-murder went to jail
for murder
yeah it makes sense yeah but they uh and
then little Wayne was super y'all little
Wayne was young Silkk the Shocker I'd
have to hear it dude
now I represent I remember that when how
we mob it's on it ain't nothing ghetto
tears no not familiar this is only his
first album he actually has a pretty
extensive discography he does seven six
studio albums ok this was in 1988 yeah
it to the game what's up oh that's it
that's it Church that's it though I'm a
song good
give me the world throw your hood up
just shoot me straight no worse I think
it's that I'm a soldier
it ain't my fault it ain't my fault
ain't my fault
yeah that's featuring mystical and then
boys is going at it back in but dude
they used to have they used to have
these sidekicks that would stand on the
side of the court and hold their extra
clothes for them to wear after they got
finished playing that rich and they
brought Reggie Brown down there who was
that Lakers uh the Celtics player that
died or something Reggie Len Bias no
Reggie Lewis I think he can't or maybe
not Regulus I don't know but they would
bring different players down there to
play with them like from like they would
be like famous basketball player he was
like really good to stop trying to go
pro and mercy he was good but then also
I sat next to him and coach one time on
a plane about three years ago was in all
white suit he was he's trying to blend
in bro yes and he had a middle seat dude
coach and I've seen him 50 times dude
when I used to go to UCLA rec center he
tried to get in there one time and he
needed somebody who was a member of the
Center to help him get in he came and I
was right there and he's like hey will
you and I was again no doubt
so no been like no tailgating just not
yeah I can't play with him at two
different college rec centers at its
really you can hoop Ike I used to be
able to really used to play a lot yeah I
hurt my back man I had a bike a partial
discectomy and I'm owed to him yeah
something about getting a piece put in
my back like what does it call two extra
hands or something yeah some sucks
rock/metal yes I could change the game
were you just playing yesterday on your
Instagram story you want one I went for
I've played a little bit out there's
co-ed would you play it but it was a lot
of Latinos dude what Tino's bro
everybody's the same height the men in
the women all five one and they're
wearing jeans dude everybody jeans one
guy kept a black night oh my god
one guy was in church pants and kept
saying that he hid a nine pointer the
same NBA J there I know 9 pointers duh
and he would shoot from half quarried
for them boys and then shoot like this
yeah
[Laughter]
so a lot of 9 pointers bro broke yeah
say you could say hey man watching King
in this thing would y'all think about
these Mexican 9 pointers that are
helping your stick bath problem all met
my buddy Jason go learned you have a
joke yeah I mean he still does is his
joke and he's so funny is like yeah I
love watching uh the Vietnamese guys
across the street playing basketball
they play 12 on 12 with a volleyball
[Laughter]
here's [ __ ] being Cheetos after 5 on
5 basketball bro
King ander sing it dude taking care of
your children anything's gonna be
possible
anything interesting it lets your
daughter date a strong brother you know
but one that's not playing athletics
that's where it's a risk you know can
your steam male nanny bro
dude I'll tell you a story so they had a
kid I used to well I guess I was a male
nanny I used to babysit these two kids
at school and I got fired actually for
her I found the parents pornography and
I would lock myself in their room and
watch it lock bro on the clock these
kids were very capable kids dude and
they were like Tina I was separate from
them they weren't teenagers but they're
how old I don't know how old kids are
twelve now one of them was 10 and the
other one's a little bit younger and the
younger was smarter I thought but yeah I
was going through some issues and some
loneliness at the time and yeah I'd lock
myself in the parents room magazines or
video videos bro damn just like now I'll
be right out nothing it just go eat your
macaroni and cheese on the brother I'll
be down in a second I feel bad and then
even had like I'd cut him up a tomato or
something quick so I can get in there
and watch the video and just put the eye
pockit
I'll be right out it's trying to jack
off no man's house damn right you got
fired bro feel bad and I actually went
back to them years later and apologized
did you refund your money uh I'm a check
I got six dollars an hour Wow
you also get what you pay for what kind
of if I'm paying six I don't expect to
do dog-walking stuff from my bathroom
and jackoff my old pornos forever now
somebody would pay me more to do that no
no one pay you you should pay them you
don't have to pay me to use my bath I'm
gonna get my porn stache bro how much
would somebody to pay you they come to
your door right it's door to door yeah
it's a door-to-door salesman all right
and they have to take a [ __ ] on my door
stuff no in your pack Oh were you from
Tallahassee no in their in your bath and
like dude I got a good thing blow it up
yeah they're gonna buy cash that bad
there's nothing
that part of you you gotta have a good
heart and you got to be a good guy he
came in I was like dude listen this is
the only house I saw I'm about to [ __ ]
my pants man and he looked like normal
dude yeah I'll come on in dude mmm yeah
bathroom
well you I don't use the bathroom in
your bedroom no it can't be my room but
here's the thing
trust your other bathroom is closed or
you don't have another bathroom cuz you
got a bad guy use the brush it you can
[ __ ] my lawn fertilizer grass no but
seriously though he's in the house he
has to [ __ ] so bad literally he has 9
seconds until he's gonna defecate cuz it
as a bi it's a bodily issue no I don't
come to my door first why no I'm not
answering the door I don't know you
broke it's America you're not old a ring
picked up does that ring camera son the
cameras gotcha from John Wow he [ __ ] in
my bath have you seen Pete Davidson
keeps dyeing his hair all the time Pete
Davidson yeah man it's crazy he said he
said they had to get off Instagram he's
getting so many death threats were
hooking up with Ariana Grande she's not
underage is she no she's the dime piece
sounds a lot of psychotic fans oh yeah
and then you know the whole Mac Miller
thing boom people out I feel like he's
like like Pete's kind of turned into her
mood ring it's like however she's
feeling that's what color he dyes his
hair does it say I'm a Pete Davidson
famine he's a good dude oh I think he's
a sweetheart
funny dude - I think he's a sweetheart
bringing the biggest dick energy - does
he have a big dick that's the word
that's what you know big dick energy
started for me Rihanna Grande
did it really yeah I didn't start it
whoever posting those memes and then
started my grande started it she did
yeah she was like Peterson has that big
dick energy the way he dresses the way
carries himself Wow yeah she started the
trend how big can someone's dick get and
still be usable I wonder yeah there's a
certain limit in there yeah and it's not
like 30 inches like it's a there's a
legitimate cutoff I feel like around it
probably eight inches woman's body can
only take so much
well you ever seen mr. hams but they can
take more than that they can take about
that much you've never seen the mr.
hands video huh gentleman died because a
horse's I don't want to watch at horses
cause that's Shaquille O'Neal these ones
have a tiny dick though really that's
the word on the street I'm sure relative
like still no like multiple girls have
came out about Shaq says he's a small
penis a friend of mine said that it
there's a there's a video of somebody
wearing Greg Odin's dick around their
neck like a scarf it's a little
Vietnamese that made sense though yeah
like wrap it around like a noose yeah
tie dicks car photos King and or sing it
man dude King yet or anything yet hell
yeah
dicks perched up on your shoulder like a
parakeet King your sting if you put the
little eyes on a few hot-glue eyes on to
it and a beak then King it but if you
just let it be there and say it's a pair
of people like uh that's a dick okay
yeah it's got a knight now it's a flesh
thing
what about this one of those new heavy
blankets have people who are selling on
the luck get the new 60 pound blanket
you'll never feel more comfortable not
too much bro staying it staying it
[ __ ] if a be blinded you're too hot I
like to go one leg out no matter what
the weather yeah yeah I said yeah that's
a trap it's not a heavy blanket no
that's a straight try bro dude that's a
trap bro that's a piece of light metal
you idiot dude you're like a baked
potato now yeah I don't want that yeah
they're like oh you'll never feel more
comfortable I haven't seen this ad but
you haven't
is that Shamu guy selling that [ __ ]
again okay yeah it's weighted blanket
yes that sounds terrible yeah watch this
somebody's selling it I don't know who's
doing it how many are they selling this
is just first but I have a 10-pound
pillow and a 200-pound mattress now it's
time for my 20 pound blanket like willow
Blanc quill
[Music]
that's some [ __ ]
while I just put a bunch of blankets on
save money bro wanted to sleep with my
jeans on you stupid [ __ ] oh my God look
how heavy it was scared at all just
arrived cracked it open and I'm gonna
try it out this is the blank will this
guy looks so [ __ ] lonely on the video
obviously very shutting down 20-pound
blanket shut it down don't forget
180,000 views yeah a lot if you wanna
know about that blanket man yeah it
sucks but love your jeans bro huh sleep
in your jeans same thing yeah well look
if you want that heavy hitter man you
can come back in two weeks we'll have
King in the sting we'll put out
information where people can submit
videos for themes it's gonna be all user
driven so if the show watch or if the
show fails it's up to you boom usually
man they can do better with in their
questions today yeah thank you yeah you
can do better than the questions that
came in today you can have a ton of
opportunity you're going to be able to
also submit videos after the themes
where you will be able to comment on and
put in your two cents for what you think
of either something a king or something
to sting or if there's a versus like a
Domino's versus yeah you give us your
take on it
yeah and the good ones will get played
on the show at the end of the week we're
gonna blast out the worst submissions we
got yeah compilation video the shittiest
ones we got yeah and none of those
wiener holes none of those wiener holy
so no dick pics don't ask any fight
questions none of that [ __ ] none of that
none of that you know did you [ __ ]
Whitney Cummings none of those kind of
questions do we want real quality stuff
on here you know and bro you know what
I'm saying
none of that uh what else dude what else
can they ask anything but fight question
we got a really weird hypothetical that
might be a good example all right boy we
were talking about male nannies Hulk
Hogan was in mister nanny so that's my
segue I just got a question for you guys
kind of a hypothetical
turn the TV off rather have sex with
a woman the wool with Emma Watson's
upper half but Hulk Hogan's lower half
or sex with Hulk Hogan's upper half with
Emma Watson's lower half whoo I love the
show keep doing what you're doing and
Brendan stay away from the [ __ ] bees
dude yeah bro yeah that honey Hunter do
I love the honey bro god damn boy I'm
down eight pounds - are you really I'm
down eight Wow
you may need a stinger herself in the
arms and legs a little then no no I'm
getting my calves bigger you need
implants bro uh-uh implants I got to do
different leg weights man a buddy of
mine gave me a real heavy piece of metal
and I can stand on the stairs and like
push my body up and down with my life
that might work once you get those jump
soles never heard of jump so I stabbed
as I would go run red shoes so I trip by
the interim yeah and then feel like
you're walking high heels for with it
yeah and that's all was for men you put
on your athletic shoe and jump with them
dude I remember running going running in
him by the interstate right like getting
for an actual run dude and I felt like
it was kind of a ledge and I I stepped
on a shady spot and slipped right off
the side like on this little levee and
somebody pulled up all right bro those
things were tough to run him oh dude so
horns out they didn't do [ __ ] oh brother
they didn't do anything dude if I swim
all the time did you really yeah I swear
them all the time I thought by running
those and I doing [ __ ] it might be just
to play basketball my friends triangle
the league bro MBA so you just said make
a league bro bro we play basketball and
they want to go the NBA bro British
novel do anything
it was exhausting dude I want to get
some of the coffee is it any good or not
I mean it's a world ranked bro is it
really yeah [ __ ] racket the coffee
Association of America yeah bro world
ring bro
how did it sell out in the first week
yeah
back world right world [ __ ] right
that's the craziest two words to put
together ever it's right probably 90% of
the countries in the world can't afford
the coffee that one's grown ain't mine
bro
who is that no that's right that [ __ ]
stole my trophy well look let's get this
guy's question and then I'm gonna say
Emma Watson is that Hermione Granger I
think Emma's mixed up yeah yeah she's
who she Hermione Granger Oh blah and she
was in Harry Potter so I'm gonna go with
she's like I'll go Emma Watson's a kid
no she was she's an adult nail in my
movie now though I like these oh she's
too young bro she's an adult so that's a
kid bro it's not a kid how old is she 30
26 [ __ ] no she was she was in bumble
face three [ __ ] uh Harry Potter you
guys get any tighten up 28 28 then I
don't buy it
Emma Watson right she's she's a she's a
Dominican Republic 28 well look bro 13
bro I'm gonna take a Hulk Hogan top in
her body cuz I'm I look actually I don't
I'll take either one bro Hulk Hogan face
and her body I'm out ho ho Killeen
stupid tits and her lower back look I
need the details brother
the guy has to dude he's won here
listeners its waist up Emma Watson or
waist down Hulk Hogan or vice versa
multi like you want to suck dick or you
forgot about Emma Watson lower body yeah
oh I'm gonna put it in Hermione bro
that's all I'm saying there's more
details though bro oh sorry Brenda needs
more details when it's as blatantly laid
out as it could be oh man any more
details yeah any more details about
everything but you guys gonna get more
details next week about King in the
sting
burn and shower just want to thank you
for coming on finally I mean I'm finally
broke yeah and you guys are killing it
on there dude dude yeah I not appreciate
your support man you guys have been
helpful having me over there I'm firing
the kid you know only had to go on about
seven times before you finally agreed to
come over here but I mean
yeah but no man I really appreciate you
guys have been so good to me over the
past couple years and I appreciate the
support you can see the strap right here
bro ah bro you know that man yeah your
boy dick Crowell brought it though he
did it Shawn brought it shiny cruel
brother did he really he brought it I
met to go listen to that yeah he brought
it he was hilarious
we'll see man we'll see though you're
tough to be I might have one more
visiting me this year well you know
we'll see about doing the show together
tough oh yeah that's true I know what do
we do then can I even run be in the
running
I mean yeah if you come on and kill it
but then it's like I know huh stuff mmm
well we'll cross that bridge when we'll
cross that bridge when we get to it yeah
all right man thank you guys so much um
when's this come out this comes out on
Thursday come see me in Seattle Bellevue
Thursday Friday Saturday yep this week
bro parlor live Bellevue come see me as
Charlotte I'll be at there Charlotte
funnies Charlotte comedies the comedy
zone and I'll be there for Thursday
Friday Saturday and I'm excited about it
next weekend or this weekend who cares
just some time look and see October 2nd
3rd and 4th I think and uh and then
we'll both be in Phoenix at the end of
October 27 28 going 200 tickets left for
that Late Show first show sold out
that's crazy man 300 tickets October 6
is a Saturday mm-hmm so I think you're
four five six okay yeah October 4 5 6
yes you're alive yeah there bro get your
dates right so I got a great producer
man um on behalf of all of us here thank
you so much Brendan will talk to you
guys soon yes sir
[Music]
it's gonna take
little time for me to set that parking
brake
[Music]